let me take a second it's been a while
since i checked in with my good friend
andy richter i'd like to see how he's
doing
hey andy how are you hi conan you are
conan right
yes we haven't seen each other in a
million years
you rascal uh no i'm doing okay i'm
hanging in there these are strange times
yeah trying to find ways to stay busy
what about you
oh same yeah i mean you know
kids and dog and chores but yeah that's
pretty much it
you know i was thinking about the other
day i know you're a baseball fan you
must be looking forward to the season
starting up in a couple of weeks huh
i am a baseball fan specifically
a fan of korean baseball their season
started months ago and i'm hooked
you know andy i didn't know you'd gotten
into korean baseball
oh how could i not it's literally been
the only live sport being played in the
world for the last three months
sure you have to stay up till 2 30 in
the morning to watch the games
but it's worth it when you've got heavy
hitters like luigi yang
helping the nc dinos dominate this year
or
or taehyun wan pitching six straight no
hitters for the samsung lions
of course you can't talk about pitching
without mo ku
and his .51 era this season he's a lefty
too can you believe it
that's incredible you know i can't
believe you caught up this fast
oh not as fast as semwo jun stealing
bases for the kt
whiz you know the biggest problem i have
is that i don't have anyone to talk
about this stuff with
i mean especially all the controversy
with the key womb heroes
oh you mean their owner chang sook lee
was convicted of embezzlement right
yes i mean and can you believe jungkook
kang wants to return after all that
with three duis on his record that
sounds like the perfect fit for that guy
well conan i had no idea you were into
the kbo too
oh yeah i'm a huge doosan bears fan
doosan we
[Music]
from
[Music]
[Music]
tucson bears tucson bears sun bears yes
bears they're great wow hey andy this is
great uh do you want to watch the kt wiz
game together tonight at 3 a.m
uh yeah that's okay i mean um i actually
like to watch it by myself so i can
really focus
what what are you talking about this is
perfect i mean would get to hang out
oh come on you know what you're breaking
up um uh uh
my wi-fi is terrible i i think i'm not
gonna have to
have good wi-fi what are you
[ __ ]